Transcriber: sarah alshurafa
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
يعطيكم العافيه جميعًا.
أتعرفون أن 83% من النساء و74% من الرجال،
لا يعجبهم شكلهم الخارجي.
دعوني أسأل سؤالًا.
كم واحدًا فيكم استطاع
التخفيف من وزنه، فليرفع يده؟
مدهش!  والله عدد ممتاز.
حسنًا، هناك سؤال آخر، مَن فيكم
استطاع تخفيف وزنه وحافظ عليه، فليرفع يده؟
نعم، لكن انخفض العدد قليلًا.
هناك سؤال ثالث، مَن فيكم خفف من وزنه
وحافظ عليه وساعد غيره في تنزيل وزنه؟
أترون انخفضت عدد الأيادي كثيرًا،
لا سيما عند آخر نقطة بشأن مَن ساعد غيره.
هذه هي قصتي اليوم،
هذا ما أريد التحدث فيه إليكم اليوم.
سأبدأ من قصتي، قصتي هي أنني شخص عادي،
كانت كل حياتي عادية بما فيها طفولتي،
في المدرسة، أنا طالب عادي وعلاماتي عادية،
لم أكن رياضيًا ولا سريعًا ولا مميزًا.
تخرجت من المدرسة بشكل عادي،
واشتغلتُ أيضًا بشكل عادي،
إلا إن وصلتُ إلى مرحلة
وجدتُ فيها نفسي في إطار يتجاوز اللازم،
وزائد عن المفروض.
زاد وزني بشكل غير طبيعي،
وعندما يزيد الوزن لهذا الحد،
يصبح هناك مشاكل أخرى؛
أصبحتُ أعاني من انزلاق غضروفي في ظهري،
وأصبح عندي مشاكل هضمية.
وصلتُ إلى مرحلة أنه رغم صغر سني،
إلا أنني أتناول أدوية،
ولا أستطيع الوقوف بسبب آلام ظهري،
ولا أستطيع الجلوس أيضًا بسبب آلام ظهري،
كان عليّ الاستلقاء دائمًا.
وبنفس الوقت عليّ تناول الأدوية
حتى يعمل جهازي الهضمي باستمرار،
وخوفًا من الإصابة بالحموضة والانتفاخات.
ليس هذا معقولًا لا سيما  ما زلتُ شابًا
في عمر العشرين وأعاني من كل هذا.
حسنًا، عندما أصل
إلى عمر 60 سنة، ماذا سأفعل؟
وربما لا أستطيع تناول أدوية جديدة في عمر
65 سنة لأنني تناولتها وأنا في العشرينيات.
في هذه اللحظة، قررت تغيير أسلوب حياتي.
أن ألتزم في ممارسة الرياضة،
وأغير نظامي الغذائي،
وألتزم في تناول أطعمة شخص رياضي،
وأحاول مساعدة نفسي أولًا.
وبشكل موازٍ، كان والدي موجودًا في حياتي.
لم يكن والدي مثلي، ولم يكن شخصًا عاديًا؛
كان والدي شخصًا يتمتع بكاريزما عالية،
كان رجل دين ورجل إصلاح له تأثير بين الناس،
يتمتع بمكانة بين الناس.
أصيب والدي بمرض السرطان،
عانى منه كثيرًا، وبصراحة،
لم يكن يعاني بقدر ما كان يحارب السرطان.
وبنفس الوقت كان المرض بالنسبة إليه
وكأنه مصاب بالرّشح أو إنفلونزا عادية.
وكنتُ بشكل موازٍ مستمرًا في الرياضة
وفي تخفيف الوزن وفي التغذية السليمة.
وغيرت أسلوب حياتي،
وغيرتُ كل ما كنتُ أقوم فيه سابقًا.
وفعلًا، نقص وزني وتغير شكلي.
وتوفي والدي - رحمه الله -
كانت وفاته نقطة تحول كبيرة بالنسبة لي.
بالإضافة إلى أن جسمي قد تغيّر،
رأيتُ أيضًا ...
عندما توفي والدي، رأيتُ تأثيره على الناس.
عندما حضر الناس لتقديم العزاء في والدي،
كنتُ أرى أشخاصًا لم أعرفهم من قبل،
وكانوا يروون لنا قصصًا حدثت قبل 30 سنة؛
أن والدي ساعدهم في أمرٍ ما،
وأن والدي أثر فيهم بشأن هذا الأمر.
كانت هناك أمور كثيرة حتى رأيتُ الدموع
تنهمر حزنًا على والدي من أشخاص لا أعرفهم.
في تلك اللحظة، عرفتُ أنه ينبغي عليك
أن لا تكون شخصًا عاديًا.
كنتُ عاديًا، لكن من تلك اللحظة،
أصبحت هناك نقطة تحول.
يجب أن تترك أثرًا وراءك.
من الضروري أن لا تكون شخصًا عاديًا.
إنه لأمر غير صحيح أن تعيش دنياك
وتخرج منها عاديًا.
يجب أن تترك أثرًا،
وعليك أن تترك بصمة.
عرفتُ قيمة هذا الأمر
وقدرته كثيرًا بعد وفاة والدي.
ومن هنا بدأت ...
بعد تخفيف وزني وتغير جسمي؛
حصلتُ على شهادات رياضية،
وسجلتُ أيضًا في العديد من دورات التغذية،
وسجلت في دورات رياضية عديدة،
وأصبح الأمر بالنسة لي أكاديميًا أكثر.
واشتركتُ في بعض مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي،
ووجدتُ أن مجرد مشاركة يومياتي أحيانًا،
فإن هذا الأمر كفيل بمساعدة أشخاص آخرين،
بمعنى أنها تؤثر على أناس آخرين.
ليس بالضروة أن يكون التأثير مباشرًا،
وليس بالضرورة أن يكون في الحال.
هناك تأثير يظهر بعد شهر،
وهناك أشخاص يتأثرون بعد ثلاث سنوات،
لكن هناك تأثير.
أقوم بعمل أشياء صغيرة
التي تساعد أناسًا آخرين؛
مما رفع هذا الشيء من معنوياتي الداخلية،
وزاد أهمية وجودي كشخص.
لم أعد شخصًا عاديًا، أصبحتُ شخصًا مؤثرًا،
أفتش عن الاختلاف،
لكن ليس الاختلاف الخالٍ من المعنى؛
الاختلاف الذي لا يحمل مغزى،
الاختلاف من أجل الأضواء والشهرة فقط.
لا، الاختلاف في صنع التغيير
في حياة شخص ما والتأثير به.
يصلني كل يوم رسائل تقول؛
شكرًا على المساعدة، وشكرًا على الفيديو،
وشكرًا على حديثك وشكرًا على التمرين.
كلامك غيّر حياتي وساعدني،
ويحمل كل ما تقوله معنى بالنسبة لي.
وأقول لأي شخص موجود بيننا،
أريدك أن تعرف أنه ضروري
أن لا تكون إنسانًا عاديًا.
ففي أي مجال تريد العمل به،
أو مهما كانت مهنتك أو هوايتك،
لا تكن عاديًا، كُن شخصًا مؤثرًا،
حتى لو كنت تؤثر على أخيك،
وأختك وجارك وعائلتك.
التأثير ضروري.
نحن ضيوف على هذه الدنيا،
يدخلها كل شخص ويخرج منها بسرعة.
في هذه المرحلة أنت كضيف،
ليس من الضرورة أن تكون ضيفًا
تُنسى ملامح وجهك وأن لا تكون كبقية الناس،
تدخل الدنيا وتخرجها بقول مع السلامة فقط.
الأصل أن يكون لك تأثير
وبصمة في هذه الدنيا.
وأن تساعد غيرك،
بمعنى أن تساعد على أي مستوى؛
يعني أخيك وعائلتك وحارتك ومستوى
أكبر قليلًا مثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
يجب أن تكون شخصًا مؤثرًا.
في الحقيقة، من خلال المرحلة التي مررت بها،
إذا قلت أنني قمت بهذا الشيء لوحدي،
فأكون شخصًا غير صادق.
صراحة، تلّقيت مساعدة الكثير من الناس؛
منذ بداية انخفاض وزني،
إلى بداية ممارسة الرياضة،
تلقيتُ مساعدة من عائلتي أولًا،
ومن زوجتي ومن الجميع،
ومن أصدقائي وأشخاص تعرفت عليهم.
صراحة، اسألوا، لا يوجد أحد سألته،
أو لجأت إليه للمساعدة وخذلني.
كنتُ دومًا أجد الإجابة.
الفكرة هي عليك أن تسأل وستجد المساعدة.
حتى تتغير، فالأمر ليس سهلًا،
أن تنقل نفسك من مكانة إلى مكانة.
أقول لكم أن الأمر ليس سهلًا،
لكن استطعتُ القيام بها،
لذلك، فأنت تستطيع ذلك.
ستجد مساعدة الناس لك،
لكن يتوجب عليك أيضًا سؤالهم.
وفي النهاية، الحياة عطاء.
والحياة تأثير كما هي مشاركة.
كُن شخصًا مؤثرًا واصنع التأثير
حتى ولو كان على مستوى صغير.
وفي النهاية، يعطيكم العافية،
وشكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)
يعطيكم العافية.